let's go uh we're kind of going around
the world a little bit uh today let's go
to is it
sauger from melbourne australia
uh hey david it's melbourne australia
okay so
sagar beautiful welcome
yeah um so two quick questions uh number
one there was a book that came out
recently this week
it was called a 100 democracy the case
for universal voting as well as two
washington op-ed pieces i was just
curious because i watched one of your
videos from seven years ago
and uh you seemed in favor of universal
voting
but you were more you weren't really
strong in your conviction i do wonder
seven years later and the and seeing the
advent of the trump administration
and voting suppression
have you become stronger in your
conviction for the case for universal
voting now just to be clear do you mean
mandatory voting
uh yes
oh yeah here's the thing i'm i'm not i'm
not big i'm big on everybody voting but
i'm not so big on mandatory voting i i
respect the idea
that opting out of the of participating
is a valid expression of of politics
what i disagree with is people who don't
vote because of apathy people who just
don't pay attention people who don't
care so for me it's not about force
everybody to vote and in fact if you do
that
that that might that could potentially
be a disaster i'm more about i want to
work towards a system or a framework
where everybody wants to vote i want
people to want to vote rather than to
force people to vote does that make
sense
no yeah i completely understand because
i was also the similar opinion because
i'm i'm originally from canada and i
moved to australia about eight years ago
so i was with you on the whole like i
want to just make it as easy as possible
for people to vote
but the thing i've noticed because
australia does have mandatory voting and
as now as a citizen i see that there's a
very strong case for it because uh first
of all the elections here are held on
saturdays
so it's pretty easy to vote already
and so really the only thing that could
come in hand is voter apathy and my very
strong belief i believe voter apathy is
corrosive to democracy i agree it is
extremely close to democracy and as well
as the election days here an event so if
you head to a polling booth you're gonna
have a sausage you're gonna have drinks
it's gonna be you're going to have time
to to talk with the
uh uh representatives from the from the
from the parties sure and and it's
become it becomes this cherished
institution and i do believe and also
the in addition to the whole mandatory
thing it's a 50 fine here and for the
most part two-thirds of those fines get
waived
and so for the most part there isn't
much of a penalty but it's just it's
just this thing that has become
ingrained in australian society
of voting and it's like and it's when
you look at the results it's 96 percent
turnout 95 turnout very high turnout and
it's really and again in my very strong
opinion uh if you want to maintain a
democracy
voting needs to be a civil duty similar
to you know how taxes is paying your
taxes as a civil duty i believe that
voting should be just as strong all
right well you've made a very strong
case for it and i'm willing to listen to
arguments uh in in that direction thank
you for the uh for the phone call
thank you so much david
very powerful call i must say extremely
well prepared that's really the
that is actually
the call everybody should aspire to
couple minutes long
polite
good audio
right to the topic prepared beautiful
beautifully done
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below